plus
[Musique]
oh
la gironde entre les marais la rivière
les forêts est tout près l'océan qui
gronde
[Musique]
les gens d'ici n'ont jamais été très
riche juste heureux de vivre à l'air
libre comme on dit ou libre comme l'air
[Musique]
isolé ce bout du monde a attiré quantité
de réfugiés espagnols portugais polonais
des prisonniers allemands et des soldats
américains aussi tous sont restés ces
gens durs labeurs se sont longtemps
partagé une mine à ciel ouvert
le gisement d'huîtres sauvages de
l'estuaire gigantesque
il suffisait de se baisser
[Musique]
aujourd'hui encore tout le monde se
souvient l'huître c'était de l'or
non
architecte originaire de bordeaux
doudou est venu s'installer dans la
région au milieu des années 70 amoureuse
de josé fils et petit-fils
d'ostréiculteurs elle n'a pas hésité à
abandonner sa carrière et la vie en
ville pour profiter elle aussi de ce
petit coin de paradis et à 50 ans ici tu
avais une partie où c'était entre
guillemets des amateurs c'est à dire
qu'il devait y avoir entre 30 et 50
vrais professionnels qui étaient
ostréiculteurs et après les 3000
personnes qui vivaient en partie de
l'ostréiculture c'était des gens qui
avaient un autre métier il y avait des
agriculteurs etc qui profité de la
période de drague qui était ouverte à
tout le monde
kid et rocchi qui revendait les huîtres
aux courtiers et ça partait en charente
d'arcachon peu importe mais disons que
c'était c'était un peu le coffre-fort où
chacun venait se servir et qui était
ouvert à tout le monde est la toute fin
des années 70 le conte de fée vire au
cauchemar
non seulement l'activité pétrolière
s'est développée mais des scientifiques
découvrent de cadmium dans les eaux de
la gironde
un métal lourd polluants dangereux pour
la santé
le ramassage des huîtres est aussitôt
interdit c'est la catastrophe
l'équivalent local de la mort de la
sidérurgie dans l'est de la france
beaucoup baissent les bras mes doudous
s'acharne
elle a l'idée d'acheter deux jeunes
huîtres scène d'arcachon qu'elle élève
ensuite dans les marais que le cadmium
n'a pas contaminé
et ça marche les pouvoirs publics
finissent par autoriser une poignée
d'ostréiculteurs à continuer de
travailler
au départ on avait un peu l'impression
du pot de terre contre le pot de fer on
n'avait pas beaucoup
on n'était pas nombreux pour faire ça et
puis petit à petit mais on s'est démené
on s'est battu on s'est obstiné parce
que c'est quand même des métiers où il
faut des investissements relativement
l'eau et quand on est jeune qu'on n'est
pas aidé par la famille qu'on a que sa
force de travail c'est pas évidente
d'avoir de la trésorerie d'avancé
et puis les brook et sont frileux et cci
la croix et la bannière pour trouver un
banquier qui vous suivent comme et ça
c'est dramatique
or si on y réfléchit mais les
entreprises individuelles c'est elles
qui font la moitié des emplois en france
mais c'est encore beaucoup plus les
victimes de la crise de l'huître n'ont
guère le choix
quelques uns se font embaucher sur les
dogues de bordeaux
d'autres deviennent pêcheurs
je t'ai défiler un jour à l'océan un
autre sur la rivière gagner de quoi
s'acheter son propre bateau et partir au
large
ça a été le choix de vie qui
si tu peux faire une vie avec un métier
comme ça pas forcément pour loger des
millions à la banque doit et déjà pour
vivre quelque chose qui te plaît levée
des filets levée des casiers et pas dire
je m'en vais au travail jouent les
canaux maritime on dit en attendant que
le poisson atterrissent
c'est à dire du large pendant les pannes
à l'émigration libérateur
quand même intéressant qu'à total dans
des coins comme chez nous de pouvoir et
sur un marché où tu peux discuter que
nos pêcheurs vous avez péché quoi
comment le poisson les fruits de la
journée toi c'est ça qui s'aiment pas ça
ça donne
si l'identité d'un coin
l'eau pendant 20 ans vicky à gagner sa
vie comme des centaines d'autres avec la
sole le bar les crevettes avec la lgv 1
dans gi sur la rive nord de la gironde
ont dit la civelle et au sud
on l'appelle la pibale peu importe les
chinois la paix une fortune jusqu'à 800
euros le kilo au début des années 2000
la parenthèse enchantée ne dure pas
longtemps
le fils vent diminue et c'est à nouveau
la crise l'europe réduit les périodes de
pêche interdit les exportations vers
l'asie à rafik ce les prix vers le bas
arrête un les pêcheurs abandonne la
pibale est pour beaucoup la pêche tout
court
lee qui résistent plusieurs hivers mais
il finit par baisser les bras
l'ami ludo lui n'avait pas le choix
trop jeune avec des investissements trop
lourds
salah ludo atari va terminer le bateau
merde on te louper et ouais l'accord va
se garer là
je vais partir mais c'est une petite
anguille monnaie c'est 2 2 ira en appel
donc la main soit un peu humide parce
que doivent aller vite séchées pour elle
et elle est maire ce petit âne où
l'attend la très belle anguille de fins
de migration apparemment mettrait deux
ans pour pour faire la migration de la
mer des sargasses à ce cas chez nous les
chouettes on est bien on est happé tard
fait pendant le traité sur thomas a
quand même et il tente plastifiée quoi
est unique
tu as parlé au chalet
avec l'instauration des quotas de pêche
les contrôles contre le braconnage ont
été renforcées ce qui exaspère les
derniers pêcheurs officiels comme le
doubs se mouvoir
résa pour débarquer mon poisson du
bateau pour l'amener chez moi je suis
obligé de faire une fiche de pêche pour
traverser la route
là il ya peut-être un bateau qui va
rentrer en allant battre doit chercher
le port là j'aimerais qu'ils nous ont
pondu ça ya quelques années quand je
pêchais le combat il fallait peser à
bord du bateau tpiy balle avant de
sortir du bateau même si ta voix tu as
30 m
si tu sors ton poids sans le savoir fait
ça peut être contrôlée ça peut te coûter
dans les 2000 euros d'amendé
[Musique]
il était 4 heures du matin quatre mini
matin j'arrive je mets dans mon bassin
et je m'en vais dormir
les flics qui m'arrive pas contrôler
qu'est-ce que vous avez mairie d'epinal
elles sont dans le bassin comme il y en
à votre votre fille de pêcheur en prix
non demain matin quand je me lèverai
quand je venais pour les demi-finales
aller au tribunal il a un brouillard je
laisse rentrer auprès de la pibale a
longtemps permis aux pêcheurs d'investir
dans l'achat de bateaux mieux équipées
et répondant aux normes nouvelles
maintenant il leur faut s'adresser à la
banque se soumettre aux crédits obéir à
des règles supplémentaires
tout ça ça vienne de l'europe c'est pas
voilà c'est tout et puis les députés
tous ces gens là ils suivent le
fonctionnement ils savent pas de quoi
ils parlent en plus qu'on sait rien il
connaît il connaissait pas les îles
connaissent pas la pêche
il me crée des led et des lois à tort ou
à raison les petits pêcheurs se sentent
abandonnés peut écouter en tout cas
rares sont les politiques évoquent leur
situation
ceux qui le font marque des points
l'écologie fermeture pour moi de pêche
terminé s'ouvrir enfin l'abri non plus
violent c'est la hulpe le braconnage il
est bon et plusieurs iraniens comprendre
vous pouvez lire des romans durs année
honorer nos hommes politiques d'avoir
non pas cher ouais il s'appelait le chan
o cha a appelé le jalon qui appelait
bleu marine sophie safer ma quatrième
année que je l'avais ce bateau va voir
comment on dit comment ça se passe et
s'en branle on n'a pas essayé et puis
moi je suis pour que la france gère ou
arrêtez moi c'est pas du racisme c'est
par ici
pas du tout le meilleur ami souvent est
sûre nous allons voir c'est rien à voir
la couleur des gens il a évalué m à
l'autre que son père nécessité sont
intéressants moi c'est signé
les aviser moi confié thomas et des
finances
on vous sent bien me connaître
j'ai toujours été dans mon coin
[Musique]
tél
dans les brumes de l'estuaire la colère
monte tout doucement sans faire de bruit
mais inexorablement
[Musique]
jean louis a renoncé aux huîtres à la
pêche puis s'est réfugié dans son jardin
là il collectionne les graines anciennes
plante des arbres travaille le bois
autrefois il construisait des bateaux à
la main mais capable d'affronter le
grand large
ces embarcations finit par ne plus
correspondre aux normes
elle non plus alors jean louis utilise
son doigt autrement j'ai fait le le
bateau spécialement pour pc les plus bas
la civette 7 des bateaux mais ils ont
tous été abandonné et ont couru sur
place vous vous arrêtez vous pouvez
voilà on a plus le dernier gravel à
l'année dernière
nulle régate d'euros d'accords me
débarrasser il avait un bien quand ils
arrivent ils se promènent aussi qu en
dise est marié le méthane est tous
veulent mouiller le chef et mentor mon
petit robin ah oui bon je te vends le
même système
c'était à peu près l'arrivée devient
flexible et kent a fini des phobies
marche pas où ça va pas et ses photos
aux feux de forêt c'est mieux ça
s'approche voilà j'ai plus de flair pour
la marque
alors voyez comment aider piller la la
je peux pas tirer
[Rires]
ça c'est dur aux thèmes et on peut le
faire un bar à l'honneur noisetiers et
qui tire aussi bien bon ça ça peut
servir pour la classe aussi mais les
écologistes chasse pas moi je sais
qu'avec mon père on allait à la pêche
aux filets dans le chenal
mais les poissons et sauter dans le
bateau d'emile sauter dans le bateau à
la pub
porteuse un guide je pense que c'est la
pollution déjà il ya une projection
c'est sûr plus ou moins mais peut-être
la pêche intensive quand même
la pêche intensive ces bateaux qui ont
défilé de chez pas combien de km du
chalutier grayssas km le filet les plus
d'oiseaux et pis c'est interdit donc on
peut plus se suffire à lui-même quoi de
ne pas d'explication et encore quand ils
nous le disent parce que des fois il
nous fait un procès avant de savoir si
c'est interdit quoi oui si tu arrives et
petit à petit quand même mais voilà on
pas qu on se révolte et roncq ont
quelque part ça a été une affaire
politique ou fini et puis le problème
c'est qu'on est divisée ça c'est idiot
parce que je ne serai pas des visées
mais autant qu'on aurait voulu adhérer
les politiques
moi je discutais doublé juste après
c'est le progrès c'est comme ça c'est la
vie et puis moi une fois je vais
dernière j'ai des vexé beaucoup en
révision réunion une île par les maires
des socialistes c'est il a le droit
c'est son affaire
moi on m'a donné j'ai dit je n'irai pas
casser la gueule alors qu'il se
promenait dans la rue pour le plaisir
par contre j'ai dit je casserai bien la
gueule à certains politiques et à la fin
du billet est bien depuis ce jour là il
y en avait donc désaccord avec moi et il
y en avait d'autres à côté qui disait
avec ça on aimerait atteindre par les
colts
s'accroît quand même
mais manger
j'aimerais l'ambiance est plutôt bon
enfant
difficile de déceler sur les visages
cette colère sourde qui explose
désormais à chaque élection sur les
rives de l'estuaire on vote radical
extrêmes anti système
on dit à voix haute ce que l'on pensait
tout bas la mondialisation l'europe les
géants qui veulent contrôler la pêche
l'agriculture et jusqu au grain des
jardins potagers
tout cela fait peur
marguet produits bios avatar à venir il
a bien oui serais toi
le maire de saint vivien écoute tente de
rassurer agit surtout le petit commerce
pour lui une priorité défendra marché
vaut tous les discours sur le lien
social
je pars de la mairie jusqu'à l'école où
la grande surface est lié et voyez à
certains ce que j'ai tout donné ce
centre il ya certains est relancé pour
faire un peu pouliguen certains maires
dans le coin ils ont été beaucoup
beaucoup moins intelligent d'elisa bien
qu il avait par exemple un village avec
tous puis les joueuses ont décidé qu'ils
allaient y mettre une grande surface
dans le village qui est pas loin
et puis la voyez ben y'a plus rien ne
reste plus que la grande surface parce
que l'épicerie qui en fait c'est le
ferment l'année prochaine je vous la non
à peu près on va dire ça comme ça on va
rester comme ça je crois que ça va être
le voilà justement que s'adresse le
supermarché en france qui doit le moins
bien tourner quand même réussi à nick
est un village
bon je te dirai pas qui c'est et c'était
un résultat nul
ce week-end la compagnie
qui est venu me voir il était venu jolie
blouse été élu sur le miado 3 2 ou 3 y
en a plusieurs nuits et il y en a un qui
m'a dit écoutez monsieur le maire en
résumé vous n'avez qu'à crever vous et
votre petite commune parce que je vais
interdit de venir s'installer sur ses
lumières
[Musique]
tu as des gens qui veulent un peu de
partout parce que tu as des producteurs
présents aujourd'hui la ja des
producteurs d'aspergés
ils sont pourtant largement aux deux tu
vas avoir des problèmes coeur de tomates
des petits des petites gens qui se font
leurs tomates et chez eux et qu'ils ont
le droit de venir les voir ici les
jeunes quittent la région faute d'avenir
ils sont remplacés par des retraités qui
n'ont plus les moyens de vivre en ville
c'est sans parler des vieux paysan à la
campagne il y a encore des petites
retraites des jeunes tous 6,1 g t or moi
je m'apprêtais fait rien libéral on veut
lui tu vois j'ai été chez tel ou tel
personne et bien aujourd'hui
il mangeait me faisait froid chez de jeu
par libérer le maudit eh bien il se
chauffe
oui n'ont pas grand chose à manger
lieu de ressources
wells heureux
le marché de saint vivien attire du
monde hiver comme été pour les petits
commerçants
c'est une véritable bouffée d'air j'ai
deux employés et le groupe problème
qu'on a c'est qu'on a énormément de
travail et l'été on est même obligé d'en
prendre d'autres par contre l'hiver pour
arriver à payer deux salaires c'est très
compliqué à trois mois dans l'année où
c'est très compliqué on équilibre c'est
à dire en gros on mange un programme
très bien notre vie pendant cinq six
mois et on accepte de perdre un peu
d'argent pendant 2 3 mois et plus d'être
à 0 pendant les trois heures et après on
met notre vie sur 6 mais c'est très
compliqué j'ai la chance de trouver un
boulot à l'année il ya quand même des il
ya quelques artisans il ya des masses
ans il ya quelques trucs
il n'y a pas beaucoup on pouvait après
les grande majorité ils attendent la
saison
les jeunes travaillent aussi trahi six
mois par an si c est le temps il n'est
pas forcément facile à vivre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai plus le curé me reste l'elysée
de cloche pour l'instant
c'est parce que quelqu'un oui je vais
pas arriver sa voix
oublié lui trop la pêche et
l'agriculture en l'absence d'industrie
le tourisme semble la seule activité
capable de créer des emplois juste l'été
c'est le problème sauf avec les chevaux
là il y a de quoi faire toute l'année
des terrines air et maréchaux ferrants
sont très sollicités
je fais entre 800 et 1000 km semaine
parce que je ne peux pas te dire
exactement
j'ai deux gps 1 que le programme pour
allécher le client est un que je
programme pour le client d'après comme
ça je sais exactement quand j'arrive
chez mon premier client combien de temps
je me trouve ce pour aller au but pour
second et donc combien de temps j'ai
pour travailler de lui tailler sa bosse
on peut craquer et oui ok et puis comme
je faire un rallye à ou est-ce que tu
pars augure pour ça tu pas trop loin
écoutez pour une fois quelque chose dans
le pays pour en profiter
fais pas le qatar n'ont pas manqué un
petit peu sur le pont quand je me suis
installé
je me suis dit je fais pas ça pour
m'enrichir
c'est ça pour m'en sortir financièrement
parce que j'aime ce métier que bah c'est
le matin même s'il faut se lever très
bon ben je n'aurai pas de mal à me lever
ce que je vais faire ce que j'aime on
aime à l'envers après il faut qu'on
aille sur l'enclume pour adapter
exactement le faire à la taille du pied
donc là il n'y a pas besoin de lui mais
le gars las d'attendre que ça chauffe
pour faire de la fumée du bruit et
l'odeur de la corde mais ça se passe pas
à l'écran les fifi les chaussures pour
en vivre il faut à au moins 4 150 jours
je dirais dans la clientèle on va
réussir à travailler un peu tous les
jours et gagner sa vie quoi
moi quand j'étais gamin je me suis pas
dit je met ma réaction
je voulais être cavaliers je voulais
sauter des obstacles galoper je voulais
pas prendre des pieds nettoyer toute la
journée quoi c'est pas forcément ce
n'est pas attractif au premier regard
après ski attractif moi ce que
j'explique aux jeunes c'est que dans ce
métier là on peut être son propre patron
avec très peu d'investissements au
départ financière affronte moi je vais
travailler à bordeaux tous les jours
c'est à dire que tous les jours je fais
5 km à l'est cinq mètres autour pas de
choix cachez heureux on est caché quoi
je suis pas meilleur que le reste va
moins vite ici il ya des endroits où on
ne peut même pas le téléphone les gens
voient les pubs à la télé ils en sont la
4g nous on n'a même pas le téléphone
portable c'est qu'ils passent et nous on
a une part on n'est pas emmerdé par le
téléphone on a internet depuis le début
de l'année avant on avait internet qu'à
ça voulait venir
maintenant on l'a régulièrement mais par
contre lorsque vous êtes dans la nature
la plus complète où vous voyez que de la
nature
formé à eux
[Musique]
le mot est lâché c'est bien cette nature
incroyable que les habitants sont
attachés viscéralement refuge absolue
la cabane de chasse celle de rick est le
frère de vie qui est situé au milieu de
nulle part
[Musique]
fils de gi's américains et petit-fils
d'indiens cherokee vie qui est son frère
aime rappeler qu'ils ont appris à
marcher sur l'eau à la grande époque de
lui
[Musique]
les mares existe depuis des siècles ils
ont donné du sel bien avant de permettre
l'élevage des huîtres les humains les
ont créés protéger entretenu pour que la
faune cuisse si épanouie
ici les frères viennent chasser mais
plus encore s'isoler observer les
étoiles rêver
[Musique]
je
e
parce que toi
la chasse est finie donc visible en bleu
[Musique]
toulouges
il ya une aigrette 1 qui c'est le signe
que la chasse est finie elle se pose
toujours dans le coin de la digue alors
tu vas voir arriver à la fin d'année un
jour se lève on appelle cela la passe et
du matin et quand les usa rima aussi que
la poste est définie non mais c'est pas
rejouer ces données sont les plastiques
et lumière avoir un prénom
un bel avenir pour moi il n'était pas
voyez un coin parce que la petite pêche
est moins de protéger que la vanne de
pêche industrielle
moi j'ai risqué ma peau parce que bon on
a quand même des charges et violence
avec laquelle les services maritimes et
tout ça la sécurité le bon ma personne
que tu mais je compte pas les filets de
pêche et tout ça mais ça fait ça
représente de l'argent sur trois ans je
me suis quand même bien planté et la
magie des petites maisons
mais bon j'ai pas trop envie commence un
visage hideux de la vendre quoi je ne
quitte la tête de marins
j'aurais aimé aller un peu plus loin
mais bon c'était compliqué pour pas
forcément gagner beaucoup plus d'argent
les pivots le problème c'est de pouvoir
de pouvoir travailler comme ça il ya
beaucoup d'interdits sécurité ccg casser
mon bateau parce qu'ils font des plans
de sortie de flotte ça c'est des faux tu
casse tout bas total éboueurs d'autant
plus j'avais je ne pouvais pas négocié
de garder mon bateau pour faire la
plaisance avec mon bateau a négocié ça
mais en fait c'est juste un papier que
j'ai perdu c'est la licence de pêche la
limite les autorités pourraient être un
peu plus conciliante vous un bateau en
bon état maintenant on le sort des
bateaux fichiers pêche et vous regardez
en présence même s'il faut payer une
petite taxe supplémentaire y est on est
dans une démocratie un peu comme ça on
sait tac vie qui a choisi de peindre en
monde englouti fait des pavés de
fantômes
c'est sa manière à lui de ne pas se
laisser submerger par le temps présent a
mis bout à bout tous ça c'est pas beau
moral mais c'est comme ça mais moi
j'aime bien maintenant quand même fermé
petit tableau
allo ventures sont cassé la gueule petit
à petit c'est vraiment que par derrière
qu'il y ait eu des volontés d'aidé de
faire des choses tu vois c'est parti un
peu à l'abandon mais on n'a pas
abandonné le toit mais en fait
malheureusement les enfants sont venus
de ce bar est quand même parce que il
faut gagner sa vie quoi donc
m
soit on est là
et
parmi les sujets qui fâchent
il y a la chance presque toujours mal vu
par les gens de la ville mais qui si on
pratique comme la pêche ou la cueillette
des champignons ces derniers jours de
chasse pour las vegas
étant donné que c'est la seule chose que
je prodigue je m'échappe quelques heures
comme là je vais rappeler vers 9h30 10h
j'ai par exemple lire oui
edu a chassé tu vas avoir un nouveau
suivre parfois et après tu vas rester un
deux trois jours sera rien vendu tout
vient ici bien ici juste un petit coup
de musique
irg l'a attaquée par les écologistes
dans les années 80 les chasseurs n'ont
jamais su trouver les mots pour défendre
leur point de vue de part et d'autre les
préjugés longtemps porté la campagne
contre la ville la modernité contre les
traditions les esprits se sont crispées
[Musique]
je le détruise pas
parce que j'ai tué chez tous les gars
comme j'étais en échec de l'année
dernière pour défendre la tourterelle
les militants écologistes ont affronté
les chasseurs avec des caméras et des
vedettes de cinéma plusieurs années de
suite le choc a été frontal violent
les chasseurs ont dû s'incliner oui
j'avais le sentiment d'avoir été
incompris et rester mais je suis rouge
était hier et j'ai bientôt fini je n'ai
rien vu du tout puis à à l'unisson avec
la nature tu fais le vide à tête et ça
quelque part
on a toujours joué moi ça me ça me fait
monter des ne serait ce que parler de ce
que la nature nous souffrons et le
soufre tu viens enchères comment ne pas
avoir conscience aujourd'hui que les
polémiques sur la chasse sont bien
dérisoires les enjeux écologiques des
zones humides et des forêts devraient
inciter à la mobilisation de toutes les
intelligences là je crains une rolls
exploiter les richesses de la gironde de
façon écologique n'est plus une utopie
certains ont tenté de réintroduire le
saumon ou l'estuaire
bertrand guillon lui à développer
l'élevage de gambas sur une centaine
d'hectares de marais maison soit le rang
et il y à des emplois à la clé alors
laissez la refroidir un peu croisée en
chambre froide après ça va la vendre
on va bien
bertrand young participent maintenant la
renaissance de l'osce la culture il rêve
d'exploiter le coquillage locaux ces
levées des poissons moi je suis arrivé
ici je c'est vrai qu'il ya une trentaine
d'années j'arrive après coup j'arrive
après le pays de cocagne sénia là où on
pouvait chasser ce qu'on voulait
empêcher ce qu'on voulait où il avait
aucune règle et les règles ils ont
rattrapé
c'était un des derniers endroits je
dirai où effectivement parce qu'il y
avait de la matière aussi on pouvait
taper dedans dire il y avait de la
ressource
aujourd'hui a pu cette ressource la
pibale elle même pourrait devenir le
symbole d'une révolution tranquille sur
l'estuaire
celle que l'on pêche aujourd'hui est
destiné à repeupler les rivières
d'europe
pourquoi ne pas la faire grossir ici
dans les marais le temps qu'elle prenne
des forces
avoir une vision d'un éleveur c'est pas
forcément compatible tout à fait avec
celui qui pêchent celui qui pêche il
prend dans la nature une autre source
et puis elle valorise comme il peut
problème de la civelle c'est qu'il n'est
pas liée à la pêche exclusivement on l'a
voulu le cantonner à la pêche en disant
ils ont trop péché à civelles donc c'est
des méchants on a trouvé le bouc
émissaire s'est passé jamais si ça
et la civette disparaît parce que il ya
six sept bonnes raisons
dirait qu'elles disparaissent et les
barrages il ya la pollution les hormones
les antibiotiques dont tout le monde
coupat va y avoir les pesticides
l'assèchement des zones humides il faut
les maintenir parce qu'il faut bien des
endroits pour qu'elle réussisse
et quand vous avez la langue illico là
qu'un parasite qui vient des états unis
donc quand vous a mis tout ça vous avez
déjà bien réduit la ressource il ya
reste effectivement qui sait qu'on voit
apparaître on va le pêcheur qui pêche
qui restent n'ont donc on dit c'est lui
mais si on enlevait tous les autres
facteurs effectivement disparition
d'espèces pour se serait jamais posé la
question de savoir s'il est besoin de
quotas
après on est quand même en train de
pêcher n'a donc est ce qu'au niveau de
la pêche
on est pas on devrait pas se poser la
bonne question de dire on arrête de
pêcher les poissons quand ils sont en
maturation plein duff ou quand ils sont
saouls stades allemands savent mon avis
et d'autres réponses qu'on peut faire
c'est qu'à pêche aux réformes et là on
arrête ses conneries de pêche à l'avs
même si c'est beau
l'élevage de la pibale comme du poisson
en général est loin de faire l'unanimité
y compris dans les rangs écologistes
en attendant les petits pêcheurs profuse
d'être pris pour unique cible
l'ebit valls avons toujours un avis
tous sont les mêmes qui font la culbute
et les goûters pour nous pourrir la vie
ao à paris
vous ouvrir les portes ont travaillé au
lieu de nous donner du travail esat ex
travailler c'est
émana
[Musique]
le nombre des bateaux qui sillonnent
l'estuaire ne dépasse pas la soixantaine
soit cinq fois moins qu'il ya 25 ans les
bateaux usines eux continuent de
ratisser des fonds au large sans que
personne ne les en empêche efficacement
et maintenant parti comme c'est parti la
politique your les bateaux et les casses
quand ils font des plans de casse à
notre sortie de flotte et les licences
118 on n'a plus de licence
rapide aux licences pour les jeunes qui
à la rentrée s'il y avait des jeunes qui
entrent au bout d'un moment mes yeux
emplis de bâton ils veulent nous dire et
de l'estuaire et
le tourisme
chez nous
[Musique]
au monde
si tu as une liberté de vie
extraordinaire envisagé question les
chants sont pas contents parce qu'on
nous met des bâtons dans les roues en
permanence de plus en plus c'est des
interdictions de tous les torts des
grillages pour tous les grillages de se
rapprocher de chez toi après
l'europe nous a pas aidés à fait nous
ici dans le médoc c'est ce qu'on ressent
côtoient l'europe si longtemps nous
allons casser quoi il ya deux personnes
qui hockey film fractures au niveau des
politiques traditionnels ces deux c'est
marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon
ces deux qui sont deux bombes atomiques
tous les deux face à face à 30 i can't i
mais ils ont fait une fracture par
rapport par rapport aux politiciens
traditionnels
c'est vrai voilà c'est de ces deux gens
qui parle des vrais problèmes de ce qui
se passe en france et par rapport à
l'europe et tous les trucs ces jeunes
qui sont dans la réalité des choses
après chacun a sa préférence pour l'un
ou pour l'autre après les partis
politiques et sam et ses partis
politiques 20 il ya une fracture on
s'est fini les gens en ont marre au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle les partis traditionnels
ont été balayés comme partout en france
insoumise et france on marche on fait
des scores importants
marine le pen elle a battu des records
pourquoi la poussée du front national
mais j'avoue que je ne comprends pas
parce que comme disait un copain il ya
longtemps
le front national ils posent ils donnent
de mauvaises réponses à de bonnes
questions
bon c'est vrai mais c'est
et voilà et les gens s'imaginent que
zaher alors l'argument du discours tu en
as tu qu'ils te disent ah bah oui on va
voter front national parce que ils ont
jamais été au pouvoir on peut bien
essayé et puis si ça marche pas et b on
changera la prochaine fois oui sauf que
c'est un peu dangereux de raisonner
comme ça c'est quand même un parti qui
est bombardée quoique baume bardem
permanence par rapport aux autres partis
politiques
et ça ça je pense que ça crée une
animosité par rapport à tout ce qui est
médiatique par rapport à elle et le
peuple se rapprocher de la beauté est
élu les années 90 afin de plus 20 ans
nous avions 50 62 personne qui vante qui
voter fn est aujourd'hui nous sommes
arrivés à 400 sur 13 100 votants donc il
ya des questions à se poser c'est sûr
sur notre région
l'otan fait que nous avons conseiller
départemental clé front national
il ya une chose qui est certaine c'est
que si on était sur des municipales il y
en aurait enfin je sais pas je veux pas
me vanter mais quoi que ce soit mais au
moins 70 % à 80 % qui votent pour moi
mais là c'est une
c'était une élection nationale il faut
bien se dire c'est sûr que le nord médoc
a eu ras le bol parce que parce que
parce que parce que nous sommes loin de
tout parce que voilà dans une corsair
douzaine et déjà trois douzaines hockey
les élus locaux craignent que les
résultats du second tour viennent
renforcer les préjugés à l'encontre de
la région et maire de talent et la
commune voisine de saint vivien exprime
le malaise l'extrême droite en france
c'est entre 2 et 4 % de l'électorat ce
n'est pas 25 son électorat si des gens
se précipitent vers certaines tendances
politiques c'est que ils ne trouvent pas
satisfaction ailleurs il trouve là des
discours qui peuvent entendre même ses
discours si ces discours sont fallacieux
mais ce qui est le plus fortement
ressenties me semble t'il aujourd'hui
c'est l'absence de considération de
certains à l'égard des autres et à
l'égard de ceux qui souffrent ceux qui
souffrent des droits sur nous et on
oublie trop souvent il est facile de
considérer la société telle qu'elle
devrait être lorsqu'on est
confortablement installé lorsque l'on
souffre au quotidien c'est plus
difficile au plan national c'est en tout
cas ce que je ressens cette absence de
considération
il ya des mecs en prison pour mémoire
quoi quirky qui votent front national
parce que l'autre des gens pas trop
confiance des dégâts la confiance des
politiques ils n'ont plus c'est fini
pour ainsi dire il faudra vraiment un
baume pour que enfin 55e
et puis c'est comme ça quoi
et puis il faut bien que ça fait rien il
ya des gens qui n'ont plus grand chose à
perdre
elle est peut-être bonne alors
d'endiguement si elle est mauvaise et
bien d'autres pas du tout si elles
partent de façon si c'est l'autre
je trouve un peu prétentieux il a quand
même du mouron à se faire
ça va être difficile de lire sur les
visages ce que sera le résultat mais la
tension est là aucun discours officiel
ne semble avoir réussi à la faire
retomber le monde ancien a disparu mais
le nouveau tarde à venir est dans le
flou du temps présent les peurs se sont
installées la colère avec pour tourner
la page
il faudrait pouvoir parler d'avenir
permettre à la jeunesse de travailler
dans la région aux anciens d'accéder à
des hôpitaux au village de rompre l
isolement qui pèse il faudrait enfin
dire comment protéger une nature
généreuse mais menacé sans en exclure
ses habitants
la plus intime un mur
il révèle les résultats eux
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas je sais
pas je suis je suis je suis là le doute
c'était très chouette pour nous c'est
que
[Musique]
le front national n'est pas fait plus et
qui se cantonnaient à 30%
voilà
ma crainte
le pen le pen début du dépouillement
le pen le pen dragon le pont du mont
blanc
[Musique]
e
le pen il ya un blindé de tête
le fait
le pen
moi pas
le faible l'hôtel
[Musique]
le paye
là
[Musique]
m
esprit 1436 masques aux votants 1954
nul 28 blanc 87 exprimé millet 32,9
macron 523 voix le pen 16 ans 16
[Musique]
oui voilà je vous remercie
on croit rêver ou presque ce maudit
qu'adrian qui empoisonnent et l'estuaire
et la vie des gens pendant 40 ans aurait
pratiquement disparu enfin assez pour
que la préfecture autorise à nouveau
huîtres dans les marais exilé depuis
longtemps d'arcachon thierry fouchier
rentrer chez lui
soutenu par le maire de talent et sa
commune il a travaillé d'arrache-pied
avec d'autres en 2017 ses huîtres ont
obtenu la médaille d'or de l'affinage au
salon de l'agriculture une victoire
personnelle certes mais offerte en
partage à tous les enfants des marais
prenons jamais renoncé
lundi 25 ans a échoué deux fois pour le
retour de lui mais on a fini par obtenir
effectivement de la par l'administration
qu'elle admette que aujourd'hui en notre
bonne condition et c'est
l'administration elle même qui a pris la
décision et qui a même été un peu plus
loin finalement que nous on a fait ce
qu'on avait demandé puisqu'elle a étendu
le champ du possible ostréicole à
l'ensemble des maths c'est à dire
l'ensemble de la zone de polders que ce
soit les mares existants ou ceux qui
pourraient exister si demain on a une
filière même pas très importante c'est
bon pour j'irai l'image du secteur
puisque on a un produit supplémentaire à
proposer pour oublier qu'on a
grosse économie touristique et surtout
la l'huître permet de maintenir en
activité ces marais elle les toits elle
permet d'habiller diversité stocks du
carbone mais on l'a on s'en bat sur sur
les plans d'eau où je mets mes huîtres
en place
en fait vous faire voir quelle somme
élevée dans pas beaucoup d'eau c'est peu
le cm d'eau pas plus pour que le soleil
passe bien à travers et qu'elles se
nourrissent bien on est s'est installé
il ya des demandes
il ya une petite lenteurs
administratives et et puis il faut pour
réhabiliter surtout les marées qui ont
été demandés mais c'est l'ombre parce
qu'il ya des études d'impact il ya des
réflexions affaires et b c'est là où ça
coince un peu mais bon on espère quand
même être une bonne quinzaine vingtaine
d'entreprises et on espère quelques
jeunes qui seraient intéressés qui pour
eux se seraient mous
alors bougez pas je vais attaché
[Musique]
je serais content de voir
amen se lancer dans des métiers comme ça
ici ça mettrait de la vie sur les sur
deux régions
on a tout un tas de métiers qui sont ou
tu croques la nature la pêche
l'ostréiculture toi bon premier la con
culture qui c'est qui qui s'adapte à
tout ça mais là c'est différent pour ce
coin ici je pense que développement
durable c'est tout ce qui concerne des
métiers en rapport avec la nature
quelqu'un tu pêches fait des sous qui ne
pas quand tu veux changer des tuiles de
tôle droit b tu payes mais que pour te
le faire cette tournée comme ça un pays
il faut qu'ils tournent comme ça donc il
faut pas merdé pêcheurs les
ostréiculteurs et tout et tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis la rue notre-dame à tout ça
ça fait aussi
faire autre chose de moi j'aime pas trop
même si un autre bateau
paris
c'est sûr
si on prend le temps d'écouter de lire
dans les pensées
derrière les coups de colère il y a des
sentiments profonds puissants comme
l'estuaire ses vents et ses marais
on n'abandonne pas un univers pareille
surtout si les menaces et les chairs
ostréiculteurs paysans aussi ont un rôle
majeur à jouer pour le préserver
l'équilibré du milieu naturel va de pair
avec la paix d esprit de ses enfants
[Musique]
tu
et oui
[Musique]